on the view now
uh
you know since megan mccain left there
was this opening for a conservative host
so morgan ortegas was was on the view
filling in the role of the conservative
host adam schiff the great hoaxer on the
russia hoax and the leader of the
impeachment against donald trump he
shows up this is after we found out the
steele dossier was bs the main source
for the steele dossier just got arrested
the whole thing was funded by the
democrats it was a big op it was a big
hoax so that the obama administration
could spy on donald trump and then once
trump won could undermine the trump
administration so schiff goes on there
and just doesn't bat an eyelash just
keeps it up with the lies and lies and
lies thankfully morgan was there to rip
him a new one
so i want to ask you about something
that's in the news a lot right now um
you've been really prolific over the
past few years being the head of the
intel committee and you defended
promoted you even read into the
congressional record the steele dossier
and we know last week the main source of
the dossier was indicted by the fbi for
lying about most of the key claims in
that dossier do you have any reflections
on your role in promoting this to the
american people let's not use that as a
smoke screen
to somehow shield donald trump's
culpability
for
inviting russia to help him in the
election which they did
for trying to coerce ukraine into
helping him in the next election
which he did uh into inciting an
erection insurrection which he did um
none of that is undercut none of that
serious misconduct is in any way
diminished by the fact that people lied
to christopher steele no i think just
your credibility is yeah just your
credibility boom owned adam schiff great
stuff from morgan ortega's really nice
to see a uh a fighter on there filling
uh filling the conservative seat on the
view
probably won't last long i'm sure
they'll get some squish or somebody to
come in but
but it was really good to see adam shift
called out in this way it's so rare to
see that in the mainstream media very
strange too for him to uh
discuss the incitement of an erection
clearly he had just read the story about
the
austrian attempts to uh to cure kovitt
through their brothels adam schiff
though absolutely shameless
he says yeah just because we found out
the steele dossier was complete bs and
just because the main source for it was
just uh just arrested and just because
the guy who who wrote it in the first
place was a total spook
and uh just because uh the the democrats
paid for the whole thing uh doesn't mean
that trump isn't guilty
guilty of what all the stuff you accused
him of is bs and it was proven to be bs
well no none of that trump trump bad
trump bad and despite all of the
evidence
i'm just going to continue to deny deny
deny and push my narrative and and the
left
usually gets away with this okay when
the liberal ruling class
lies it usually redounds to the benefit
of the left almost all the time
but it's not it's not exclusively a left
versus right thing
this ruling class versus
we the ruled is not exclusively democrat
versus republican or left versus right
glad you liked that clip but hold up
don't go anywhere ring that bell
subscribe
now even still you might not get those
notifications so what i would really
recommend you go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play type in
the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you